welcome to the hundred sixty-six
commencement exercises of Hillsdale
College thank you for coming this is our
largest crowd they've been getting
bigger and bigger anyway in this year we
tried to suppress the name of the
speaker but we were unsuccessful I
welcome vice president pants and more
importantly his wife Karen who who will
soon have the honorary graduates of our
College
I think his staff the advance team and
the Secret Service who are efficient and
kind and I recognize among them
especially Stephen Ford and Ryan Murphy
who in recent years were Hillsdale
College students and we never thought
they were gonna work out where are they
anyway yeah you should go ask him how
they ever got in the place they're in my
job is to I'm Larry RN I'm the president
of the college and my job is to explain
the purpose of this ceremony because we
all have a part in it it's for all of us
it's something we've all produced it is
not ending it is commencing we are
beginning something each of us is
essential to what happens here today
none of it would have happened without
every group who is here and in the case
of the individual seniors without many
individuals who are here the purpose of
the college from its first day is the
protection a perpetuation of civil and
religious freedom and intelligent PI D
through sound learning we are commencing
to live a good life and learning and
faith add to moral character are the
essentials of that good life we call it
commenced because these seniors have
qualified themselves to commence that
they won't master it ever and not even
nearly completely us they keep at it but
they have surely been at it here you
notice a lot of us are wearing robes I'm
gonna say word about that in a minute
but first I want to recognize to thank
those of you who don't have a road
you're out of uniform
you're civilians we often talk of you of
you that way around here as in one of my
favorite things to say when I see
students doing something I always say
behave yourself kids they're civilians
around most of you are civilians and you
fall into two groups I'm gonna think the
most important civilians here first how
did these seniors come to be how did
they get here they have parents families
they have grown up to do this this is
not easy not easy even to get in here
very hard to complete it to complete it
with honor that's such a thing such an
achievement they struggle and they
strive to do it and you are the ones
who've helped them what have you done
since they came right what you've done
is you've done the phonathon
the prayer groups and you've referred
people to the college and you host
events all the time we have a lot of
events at the college and I just noticed
there's always several tens of thousands
dollars of free laborers standing it
around and they always have parent on
their sticker right here and why we have
their kid it's a common production they
flock to parents weekend think the
record attendance is 980 parents at
parents weekend it's a what you're a
marvel to us and I know you're not as
sad today as you were the day you left
them off here four years ago because now
it's kind of done and you don't to pay
for it anymore
and you're proud of what they've
achieved with the parents please stand
up
[Applause]
the rest of you not wearing a uniform
are friends of the seniors and of the
college you stand for millions of others
I don't know how many people watch the
stream of this but it'd be a lot they're
about 4 million people who are on the
mailing list of Hillsdale College they
help us in a million ways some of them
give us money but in other ways they
talk about as they help us meet people
they broadcast the message of high
learning that the combat is the
college's purpose and without that you
know I made a joke about the parents
paying for it and they do but you know
they don't pay for quite half of it
other people people who don't know these
seniors they pay for it why would they
do that they don't get anything back
come to think of it why would the
parents exhaust themselves when these
kids are 20 years old and 21 years old
to help them grow up right and they
don't get anything back either
the answer is love it is a large
community of love thank you friends all
of you wherever you are we welcome you
in the academic community we are led by
the faculty they have uniforms and they
have stripes on them to indicate their
rank
David the Provost is a graduate of the
University of Kansas and so he's wearing
the robe of the University of Kansas
that's his unit and he's wearing the
three stripes that go with the doctor of
philosophy Dean Smith is he up here
that's missed out here okay post read on
over he comes from he's wearing the
bright red robe of the Claremont
Graduate School where I happen to have
agreed from and and he's got his three
stripes too and that's his credential to
lead here in the way that he does I'm
wearing the robe of the college I have a
medallion the college's medallion when I
came to work here it's my first job in a
college I didn't know any of that stuff
and they were fitting me for this row
but I didn't know what color it should
be anything I didn't need to know people
around here know that and I said wait
there are too many stripes and I have
four and the lady said you're the
president silly do you see what that
means in formal occasions
we are designated to do what we do and
of course it's never just Authority its
responsibility what do they do these
faculty members 30 years of learning at
the least
all of them any more than that now used
to being the brightest people they know
and what they do is they deepen their
knowledge of a thing never to get rich
it's a poor way to do that in it and you
know they'd like to make it a little
more but what why did they do that right
and then they take these and these are
18 to 21 years old it's an amazingly
conventional College if you see them and
they look kind of like grown-ups it
means they're seniors and if they look
kind of like freshmen like little kids
it means they're
freshman and the transition goes in
between you can walk on somebody else's
campus and recognize it now and they you
know they're drinking from a firehose
they're young and ignorant and these
people are learning and they talked to
them into the night in class and out
they stay up with them when they need it
they correct them when they're wrong
they counsel them when they're down they
inspire them they give them the most
precious thing the thing they've spent
their lives learning their that activity
is the activity of a college I asked the
faculty to stand up so we can thank them
[Applause]
anybody not his papers great again no
nobody it's an inside joke but I'll make
it outside I've never met any human
being however great a faculty member who
likes to grade papers but we do it three
have one distinctions this year that I
always mentioned this ceremony we give
the Dougherty Award for Teaching
Excellence to a junior mentor both
faculty in the fall and a senior member
in the spring and this year's winners
are dr. Courtney Myette of chemistry and
dr. Nathan Sleater of philosophy and
religion would they stand up please
they are selected by a committee of the
faculty and it's a roll of Honor the
people who won that the senior class
conspires every year to pick a professor
of the year and this year it's Adam
Carrington of the politics department
would he stand up please
oh yeah
are you doing over there Adam oh you're
a marshal I see yeah yeah I got to
revoke his award I thought he wasn't
here to our faculty members are retiring
after very long service George angel of
theater and speech has been here for 34
years he's been chairman of that
department for 22 years he's directed 55
productions here and the ones he lists
are an insight into his character Tommy
to tempest-tossed
iron bird fusion to mirror of the
invisible world I never heard of either
of those two but he he likes him he's
been the rock of the theater in speech
Department for much longer than I have
been here and we are deeply grateful to
George angel please stand up
maybe George is not here is he already
going to see from the chemistry
department we have a biologist who's
been here for 21 years
he's a interesting guy for a biologist
he's a quiet guy you might think that
but he's a sexy phone mystique plays a
mean jazz saxophone I've heard him do it
and he restores cars and make some
beautiful old cars he knows everything
about them and in his efficient caring
way he has been a tireless friend to our
students for those 21 years and we think
and ask to stand up Bob Miller please
we do
hey Brandon where's Jorge
tell him shame on him see they're
retired now what do they care you know
I'm not as grateful as I was a minute
ago now the Provost Weiland just noticed
that this is the last commencement of
two people who haven't put their name on
the list because they're very contrary
people and they are former Provost
former acting president of the college
Bob Blackstock and his wife Jackie and I
would like to ask them to stand up
there they're retiring in December when
few people retire probably because they
want to hog glory for themselves
actually Jackie's not like that there's
so many of you I wonder if you can hear
all this
apparently I congratulate the seniors
they too are wearing a uniform it
designates their rank they have some
ribbons all of the ribbons are granted
by the college and by groups that they
join that are recognized by the college
and the ribbons indicate some
distinction or another but the chief
distinction is their black robe which is
long if you go to college and Oxford
which I did for a little while they give
you a short robe they don't actually
make you wear it it looks kind of stupid
and and that's to show that you're a
novice an undergraduate they get and
you're not to wear it it's against the
rules to wear it after you get your
degree these seniors are going to keep
these robes they're going to keep them
as a designation of their rank they have
joined the educated they are not novices
anymore the achievement that they've
made is of course chiefly theirs
each one because just try go home
tonight and do it they won't because
they're done with that for a while
go home and get some great book and sit
down and study it for three hours
it's an enormous test of the soul these
seniors have passed that test not once
and not twice but daily for a long time
that's what they've done and of course
it's their effort and their thinking and
therefore it's natural and right for
them to think that this is their day and
that is true
only in part because of course everybody
else I've named so far and for each one
of these seniors each of the other
seniors are essential elements of their
education the word college means
partnership and it will not work unless
we all work together and can rely upon
one another and we can hear and so at
the same time that they're extremely
grateful to their teachers and to
everyone here and to you who help make
all this possible they are also aware
that this has been an enormous effort to
them but I remind them and I remind all
of you it is not your effort alone
remember always all your life to be
grateful and we will remember to be
grateful to you there's a kind of a
scandal about the senior class they get
this is not the scandal they come to
senior dinner and these are very good
singers and violin players and cello
players and they make longer toasts that
a single senior class typically does
they're worthy Bunch that's fun and
interesting about them they are by the
numbers we have and the numbers are
known academic numbers you know test
scores and grade point average there of
course not the measure of a quality of a
person even of the intellectual quality
of a person but these are the best
qualified ever and I think next year's
might be better
but having said that they're just like
seniors in this they all think that the
freshmen and sophomores are nerds and
that the quality of the college is
falling off sharply and you know that's
the first time I ever heard anybody say
that except when it was said about them
here's the scandal Hillsdale College is
very unusual for a liberal arts college
it's possible it's unique it's rare
anyway we have the same number of boys
and girls next year's class looks like
it might have a few more boys and the
academic profile if you look at those
numbers I talked about for the boys and
the girls is exactly the same right and
on the other hand girls make better
grades than boys about a tenth of a
point on the average grade point average
and I'm about to ask the top ten to
stand up and you'll see what I'm talking
about
with the top 10 graduates please stand
up
the Anna Mikkel the valedictorian
biochemistry I'm sorry to report as a
4.0 we don't like that to happen around
here the Delaney layman 3.96 or
something somebody gave her an a-minus
and I'm gonna give whoever that was a
bonus and they were all girls right and
what does that prove if you put those
numbers together with that fact I just
showed you it means that boys are just
as smart as girls they're just more
often stupid but in honor of the boys
I would like Jacob Weaver the 11th
student in the class to stand back
[Applause]
Jacob is going to University of Michigan
law school right
and I had him in class when I use the
first one I thought that boy is just a
dumb as heck yeah after the
valedictorian in the salutatorian stand
up please so everybody can just look at
you two
[Applause]
we pick an outstanding senior man and
woman it's a rigorous process that
involves all the groups in the college
the interview it's hard there's a big
vote to I always vote for myself I never
win and there are always exceptional
people
Dustin platen is going into a life
charitable service in hurry
Madison frame has gone to the University
of Michigan graduate school in
biochemistry and she too has high
charitable purposes and somebody told me
that they're engaged is that true
stand up YouTube
No
yeah you're all wondering what I'm
wondering if you look at Madison and you
look at Dustin why would she marry him I
don't know that's happened once before
Zach Howard married Elizabeth Peters
Betsy Peters had been 400 Peters kids
come here and Betsy is one of the
smartest girls I ever met in my life as
is Madison and you know Zach and Dustin
you know they're pretty clever I thank
the senior class officers we together
decided to invite the vice president and
of course that introduces lots of moving
parts and trouble for everybody in the
world and I I told him that and I said
it'll be great but and you know they
there's a political article about this
morning and it's a really delicious
because all the bad parts are false but
Dad but isn't that I just decided this
right well I don't do it that way I can
if I if it weren't true that I could
then it'd be chaos right but I did it
with them and they're just a pain in the
tuchus
and that's oh I would like senior class
president Rossi Lane and vice president
nor wine rate and secretary Lauren itzel
and treasurer Casey Reeves and social
chair Claire Hughes and fundraising
chair Payton Bowen to stand up please
with the members of the senior class to
end up and please be recognized please
thank you
Razi lanes gonna give a speech later as
senior class president I don't know if
it's gonna be good but I'm sure it's
gonna be short our commencement speaker
is a man of constant and urgent business
his are the affairs of war and peace of
a great nation in the world he is the
second executive in our constitutional
republic I think how far that is from
what we do here the time and energy of
our College are consumed in things that
happened long ago or ever abide we have
almost no courses on any particular
subject of public policy people always
think you know I myself for example if I
didn't go on the radio pretty regularly
I wouldn't read the news at all it's not
true but I read it more than I would and
I read it as much as I have to we teach
old stuff right because we haven't
commenced yet that's happening today do
you see how that makes us vulnerable
because you know we don't really have
any way to defend ourselves we're not
people of urgent well I kind of am a
person of urgent affairs I have a lot of
work to do and I'm reasonably prudent
man maybe but the kind of thing that the
Vice President does people like that
they have power and you know tyrants
when they have power this is the first
kind of thing that they abolish because
why we're not learning here that the
latest guy you met with a crest on his
shoulder or something is God himself
we're actually learning about God
himself and so tyrants don't like that
do you see why it matters so much how
they rule
and in a free republic its glory is it
it protects all the rights including the
highest rights that are exercised here
the vice-president is obviously
complicated to address our body by the
constitutional office that he holds
second in the land doesn't matter
whether you voted for him or not if you
love the constitutional republic in the
representative form that's supposed to
protect our liberties he's doing that
right now but is he I wonder qualified
by reputation and character also
qualified by his inner nature by the
thing that moves him to address us here
today my favorite thing among many that
I have heard him say he said on this
campus and it was printed in him Primus
first he quotes the story from Calvin
Coolidge to show the nature as Calvin
Coolidge conceived of the executive
office Coolidge writes the day I became
president my son the son died soon after
this he lost his son had just started to
work in a tobacco field and one of his
fellow laborers said to him if my father
was president I would not work in a
tobacco field and young Calvin Coolidge
the jr. said if my father were your
father you would
then the vice-president Goss goes on to
save his own attitude to the young if
the president he's speaking of the
presidency in this speech has the true
interest of the young at heart he will
not flatter them nor let hit them adore
him for in flattery is condescension and
in adoration his direction nor should it
be the president's business to presume
to direct them it is difficult enough to
do right by one's own children no one
can be the father of a whole continent
youth to be successful statesmen have to
be assertive people to be great
they must bow before necessary things
like work and the care of their own
children and before elevated things like
learning and like God these later things
are quite beyond their power and they
must not resent but they must respect
and protect that Mike Pence is qualified
to be here today because he wrote those
things right there please welcome the
vice president United States
thank you
and thank you dr. Agra that warm and
remarkable welcome I need to remind
myself to never follow dr. Arnn to a
podium again he has become my friend I I
don't use the word mentor loosely but
president of Hillsdale College has been
a mentor to me dr. Arnn under your
leadership Hillsdale College has risen
to national prominence as never before
educating a generation to carry freedom
forward and these students and this
nation are in your debt would you join
me in showing your appreciation for the
12th president of Hillsdale College dr.
Larry arm
before I get started let me make a
promise promise to all these students
unlike dr. Arnn I will not be asking you
to define the good to the Board of
Trustees to these distinguished members
of this remarkable faculty former
governor or congressman Walberg to all
our distinguished on a recent guest all
the proud parents and all the family and
friends gathered here and most
importantly to the extraordinary men and
women seated before me today the class
of 2018 thank you for giving me the
honor of addressing this 166
commencement ceremony for this beacon of
Liberty and American ideals that is
Hillsdale College
and let me begin by bringing greetings
from a good friend of mine it was also a
great admirer of Hillsdale College he
asked me to pass along his
congratulations to the class of 2018 I
bring greetings and congratulations from
the 45th President of the United States
of America president Donald Trump
now Karen and I are really honored to be
back at this exceptional institution to
be a part of this commencement and we're
also humbled by the recognition that
will be bestowed on us today I mean
allow me to commend you dr. Arnn and the
faculty for having the especially good
judgement to honor my wife with an
honorary degree today I guarantee you
that if you were looking at the academic
averages in our family they would
reflect the academic achievement of the
top 11 graduates of this class my wife
is a career educator and author and
artist she's traveled across our home
state and across this country supporting
worthy causes benefitting vulnerable
children and our military families would
you all just join me in thanking the
second lady of the United States of
America Karen Pannell's we're here she
is an hour she
for my part I've always marveled at
Hillsdale College is long and often
lonely stand for freedom in America this
College was founded at a time of great
consequence in the life of our nation a
time when Americans were deeply divided
over the meaning and purpose of our
country and whether as the Declaration
of Independence forcefully states that
we are in fact all created equal but for
the founders of Hillsdale College the
truths of the American Founding were
just that true for all people at all
times in 1844 those men and women did
what no other college had done up to
that time Hillsdale College prohibited
any discrimination based on race
religion and gender at its very founding
they established this institution to
provide sound learning necessary to
preserve the principles and the promise
of America and so has Hillsdale done in
every era sense inscribed on central
hall I'm told are the words may earth be
better and heaven be Richard because of
the life and labor of Hillsdale College
and so it has been true but I also know
these words will continue to ring true
for generations to come because of the
men and women of the Hillsdale College
class of 2018 this is an extraordinary
group of men and women who have
accomplished extraordinary things in
their time here and they've only just
begun
366 strong representing 37 states in
five countries you've persevered through
all of the most challenging and
transformative education xeni where in
the country now it seems at times that
we live in an age of grim relativism but
here this class has seen the power of
unchanging truth to change lives you've
learned the character is destiny and
that it's essential to self-government
and that right conduct is its own reward
and it seems we we live in a time where
too many disregard that wisdom of the
past that dr. Arendt spoke about so
eloquently but here you've been grounded
in the traditions and teachings that are
our greatest inheritance in America and
the teachings and traditions that will
always be the surest foundation of a
boundless American future in a word your
education at Hillsdale has taught you
not what to do but what to be and today
you'll receive a diploma that's been
minted in Independence and tempered with
truth so for all you have done to reach
this moment class of 2018 give
yourselves a round of applause we're
proud of each and every one of you
but today is a day of celebration but
it's also a day of appreciation
especially I know I speak for this class
when I say it's especially true for
those who believed in you and helped
bring you to this day
your friends your professors and of
course your wonderful families I mean
let's be honest no one comes to a
commencement to hear the speaker in fact
if you took every commencement speaker
this College has ever had and laid them
end and it'd probably be a good thing
but all of you gathered here gathered
around this incredible class are here to
revel in the accomplishments represented
by those in the cap and gown but they
know that today is as much your
accomplishment as theirs so before we go
one step further class of 2018 would you
mind just standing up for a second turn
around catch the eye of your loved ones
your brothers sisters grandparents and
especially your impoverished parents and
just show them how much you appreciate
all they've done to bring you to this
day
[Applause]
thanks for that
today you the members of the class of
2018 will graduate from this
extraordinary college and enter new
careers and endeavors so before I go
further I'd like to take a moment to
talk about what good timing you have
you'll be glad to know the America that
awaits your energies and ambitions is
experiencing a new era of opportunity
and optimism
you're beginning your careers at a time
of growing American economy and restored
American stature at home and abroad and
I can personally attest from my travels
across this nation faith in America is
rising once again
on the world stage you've seen America
embracing our role as leader of the free
world with action just this week on Iran
North Korea and Monday America will lead
the world again when we open our new
embassy in Jerusalem the capital of
Israel
here at home businesses large and small
or growing again more than 3.1 million
new jobs in the last 15 months
unemployment is at a 17-year low and the
best news for all of you new graduates
is that there's more job openings in
America today than ever before in our
nation's history
and let me say it's no accident or
coincidence faith in America is rising
again because President Trump and our
entire administration have been
advancing the very principles that you
learned here in the halls at Hillsdale
College the principles that have always
been the source of America's greatness
and strength in this White House as the
president has said we fight for the West
with all our minds and our wills and our
souls as he said in Warsaw Poland we've
been expanding freedom cutting taxes
rolling back the regulatory state
returning authority to the people into
the States and we've been upholding the
Constitution of the United States and
defending all the god-given liberties
enshrined there including the
unalienable right to life
truth is when you leave this place
you're going to find an America filled
with promise being built again anew on a
foundation of personal responsibility
and individual freedom but I also
believe that faith in America is rising
again for one more reason for despite
the fact that we live in a time when
traditional values and even religious
convictions are increasingly
marginalized by a secular popular
culture a time when it's become
acceptable even fashionable to malign
religious belief in this time I believe
with all my heart that faith in America
is rising as well
now full disclosure people who know me
well know that I'm a Christian they're
conservative and a Republican in that
order as a good book says I'm not
ashamed of the gospel in fact it was 40
years ago this spring that I put my
faith in Christ as a freshman at another
liberal arts college not very far from
here and while in some places deeply
held religious belief is becoming more
rare leading some to claim that
America's rich faith tradition will soon
be a relic of our nation's past it just
isn't so facts are facts
faith is rising across America I see it
every day in communities large and small
in the way Americans respond in good
times and in great hardship the faith of
the American people shines forth I see
it as I travel across this great country
as countless Americans take the time to
tell us often with great emotion the
sweetest words we ever hear I'm praying
for you and I know they mean it and I
see it right now right here at Hillsdale
College an institution founded by those
who proclaim themselves grateful to God
for His inestimable blessings even as
many continue to forecast the decline of
religion in American life the truth is
as President Trump recently said this is
a nation of faith and faith continues to
exert an extraordinary hold on the
hearts and minds of a growing number of
Americans in fact the percentage of
Americans who live out their religion on
a weekly basis praying going to church
reading and believing in the Bible has
remained remarkably consistent over the
decades even as the population of the
United States has grown by leaps and
bounds I mean think about it today
relative to the population four times as
many Americans go to church on a regular
basis then at the time of our nation's
founding religion in America isn't
receding it's just the opposite
faith is gaining new life across America
everyday for my part I've long believed
that nothing is more important to the
future of this nation faith has always
been the wellspring of hope for millions
of Americans from our very founding
faith has been the foundation of our
freedom as well and religion was
recognized by our founders is essential
to the Republic it's a truth that's been
taught here at Hillsdale it would not be
a new thought for this class this is a
place where faith flourishes I I know
with admiration that Hillsdale will very
soon open your new Christ Chapel just a
few short months it'll be the largest
college chapel built in America in
almost 100 years
you know Hillsdale has always recognized
the wisdom beautifully expressed by our
nation's first vice president John Adams
who said and I quote our Constitution
was made only for a moral and religious
people and it is wholly inadequate for
the government of any other as all of
you can attest here at Hillsdale
students and professors of all different
faith traditions sharpen one another
just as iron sharpens iron and as you
prepare to leave this special place I
just encourage you to take take your
convictions into every facet of your
life add your voices and your values to
this great American experiment class of
2018 at Hillsdale College you've
received an education uniquely grounded
in American ideals but as the Good Book
says to whom much is given much will be
required and so it is with each of you
your education in the liberal arts has
empowered you to conserve the
foundations of our freedom and you are
now uniquely suited and I believe you
are uniquely called to renew the fabric
of our national life with your character
and with your ideals make no mistake
about it this is an ongoing and
monumental task it's not for the faint
of heart or the small-minded it will
require courage and tenacity and
greatness of spirit at times you will
face opposition even ridicule for taking
a stand for what you know to be right
but as you've learned here at Hillsdale
strength rejoices in the challenge
and remember the most heroic acts and
the greatest feats aren't the stuff of
headlines and fame they're actually to
be found in the daily choices that
you'll make and the habits that you've
already begun to form ultimately whether
you become a part or the deeming and
renewing the time comes down to whether
you live what you've learned here at
Hillsdale College and so I urge you with
the greatest respect continue to grow as
men and women of character continue to
forge friendships that will help you
grow as a person and pursue what's right
form strong vibrant and loving families
the foundation of our free society where
you pass along our cherished values to
the next generation continue to build
strong communities those little platoons
that shape all who dwell within them and
in the process shape America itself and
never forget that timeless wisdom once
enshrined on that old sign on m99
Hillsdale it's the people
so thank you for the honor of addressing
you today and as I close let me
encourage you
Hillsdale class of 2018 have faith faith
in yourselves proven by what you've
accomplished to get you to this very day
faith in the principles and the ideals
that you learned here principles that
bind us together as a people and give
purpose to our nation faith that America
is rising and that you have a role to
play in redeeming the time and lastly I
pray that you'll also leave this place
with faith as Winston Churchill
reflected before our Congress that in
his words some great purpose and design
is being worked out here below of which
we have the honor to be faithful
servants and trust that he who brought
you this far will never leave you no
forsake you he never will if you hold
fast to him if you live according to all
that you have learned and the examples
that you have seen in this special place
if you rededicate yourselves to the
noble mission that is always animated
the graduates of this cadre College I
just know the bottom of my heart right
after we get done making this nation
great again
your generation will make America
greater than ever before
so congratulations the class of 2018 you
did it this day is yours your future
starts today god bless you god bless
Hillsdale College and god bless the
United States of America
[Applause]